THE EMPERORS ARE GONE, AND
CONGRESSMAN, IS IT ODD TO YOU
HAVING SERVE THIS COUNTRY FOR A
WHILE AND LIVED IN IT EVEN
LONGER, AND THEY DON'T AGREE
WITH DOING THE BIDDING OF
RUSSIA.
LIKE WHERE DID THIS COME FROM.
>> NOTHING SURPRISES ME WITH
SOME OF THE MAINSTREAM.
THIS AND MORE SANCTIONS ON
RUSSIA THAN EVER BEFORE AND THIS
WHITE HOUSE WHO GAVE THE UKRAINE
TANK BUSTING JAVELIN MISSILES
WHICH THE PREVIOUS WHITE HOUSE,
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WOULDN'T DO AND SOMEHOW, THE
PRESIDENT IS SAYING THIS
WHITE HOUSE WILL HELP PRUDENT,
THAT'S THE MOST RIDICULOUS CLAIM
I'VE EVER HEARD.
AND I LOVED YOUR MONOLOGUE, I
THINK YOU NAILED IT EXACTLY
RIGHT.
>> Tucker: I SHOULD SAY FOR
THE RECORD THAT I'M TOTALLY
OPPOSED TO THESE SANCTIONS AND I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE AT WAR
WITH RUSSIA.
WE SHOULD PROBABLY TAKE THE SIDE
OF RUSSIA.
>> TELL ME WHY -- IT CAN'T BE
BOTH.
SO LOOK.
YOU HAVE -- THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, HE SAID
PRESIDENT TRUMP -- I DON'T GET
THEIR LOGIC AT ALL BUT, I DON'T
GET MUCH OF WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
THEY'VE BEEN PUTTING THE NATION
THROUGH OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS.
>> Tucker: WOULDN'T YOU
THINK -- THERE WOULD BE AT LEAST
A MOMENT WHERE PEOPLE SAY,
PROBABLY CONCEDE THAT WE WERE
WRONG.
WE COULD CONTINUE TO BOMBARD YOU
WITH ALLEGATIONS ABOUT RUSSIA.
>> YOU ARE NEVER GOING TO GET
THAT ESPECIALLY FROM FOLKS THAT
YOU HIGHLIGHT A NEW MONOLOGUE,
THEY JUST DOUBLE DOWN AND KEEP
PUSHING ON.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU SEE FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND WHAT DID HE DO?
HE MOVED ON TO THE WHOLE UKRAINE
STORY THAT WE'VE NOW BEEN LIVING
THERE FOR THE PAST TWO MONTHS.
THEY NEVER BACKED UP AND
APOLOGIZED, THEY NEVER ADMITTED
THEY WERE WRONG, THEY KEPT
PRESSING FORWARD.
WHEN SHE CALLED THAT IMPOSTER
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
THEY'VE NEVER ACCEPTED THAT
FACT, AND THEY ARE OUT TO GET
THEM.
THEY GO FROM ONE THING TO THE